-Sebastian, welcome back.
-Oh, good to be here.
Great crowd, great band,
great host.
-Oh, my God. That's what I'm --
You look sharp.
You look great.
By the way, backstage, I noticed
you don't have an entourage.
-No, I come solo
to these things.
There's a lot going on
back there.
A lot of people bringing
a lot -- 30, 35 people.
And I look at that, and I go,
"Every head is cash."
[ Laughter ]
-That's -- Yeah, that's right.
Okay, I see. Yeah.
So, you don't mess with that.
Can I just tell you how great,
by the way --
The special is fantastic.
-Thank you.
-"Is It Me?"
You got to watch.
And we'll get into that.
But also, just all of
what you've done
in your whole comedy.
I was going to send you this.
I was telling you backstage,
there's kids -- This one kid is
doing an impression of you so
good, a fantastic impression.
I go, "I'm going to send that
to Sebastian."
And then I flipped and I saw
another kid doing you.
And then there's like
thousands of people.
Everyone's --
Does that feel good
when people do impressions
of you?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't like it.
-No, it's flattery.
I like it.
-I mean, this is it.
-Yeah, no, it's nice, man.
I never thought I'd get
to this point.
I never thought I'd be
sitting here
talking to you on
"The Fallon Show."
I mean, come on.
-Oh, come on, buddy.
I'm so happy.
I'm thankful you're here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you're here
during the holidays.
-Love it.
-How was your Thanksgiving?
-So, let me tell you about
Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
I don't like when people make
food at their house
and then bring it to my house.
Right?
-Uh-huh. I understand.
-It's always leaking, you know?
[ Laughter ]
There's, like, a trail
from their car
to my kitchen.
-Okay.
-And it's always unidentifiable.
They got to explain what it is.
They're like,
"It's a family recipe."
[ Laughter ]
"It's a little cinnamon,
pecan, chicken --"
Chicken?
[ Laughter ]
I'm always wondering
where to put it.
I'm like, "Put it
near the garbage."
[ Laughter ]
-That's the close place
to put it. Yeah.
But are you in
the Christmas spirit here?
-I am in the Christmas spirit.
I'm making eggnog this Saturday.
[ Laughter ]
For a --
Yeah, so, we're going to have
a party Saturday at the house.
Right?
I wanted it small -- 14 people.
I'm going to make
a little eggnog,
have the people come over.
But my wife, it's ballooned to
65 people, alright?
Now, the recipe only goes to 14.
So I don't know what I'm going
to do now that there's 60.
And it's ballooned where --
My wife is so creative.
She's an artist. She's like,
"What if we get a reindeer?"
[ Laughter ]
-So -- Yeah.
-Wow.
Like a real -- a reindeer?
-Yeah, she wants -- Listen.
We've had these parties, these
elaborate parties, and listen.
I'm from the Midwest.
I'm very --
[ Cheers ]
Yeah, from Chicago.
Our parties were very simple
growing up.
Played games.
There was nothing --
-Yeah.
-Nothing too --
-Fanfare.
You don't need a big thing.
-No.
But my wife, she's got to be --
"What about a Santa
on the roof?"
We're not getting
a Santa on the roof!
[ Laughter ]
-But do the kids like it?
How old are the kids?
-It's not even a kiddy party.
This is adults.
-This is --
You're having eggnog.
-Eggnog for 65 adults,
and my wife wants a reindeer
walking around in the yard.
So I said -- I had to put a --
-Walking around in the yard.
-Yeah.
-How old are the kids?
-They're 5 and they're 3
and I'm 49.
And that's a 46-year gap.
[ Laughter ]
And for the older parents
out there,
you start doing math
if you're older, you know?
I could very well be
in a wheelchair
at my daughter's wedding, right?
-Oh, my God.
-They'll just wheel me in.
There will be
a 10-minute discussion.
"Where do you want to put Dad?"
[ Laughter ]
-"Where do you want to put Dad?"
"Where do you want to put Dad?"
-Yeah.
-That's hilarious.
You've had a great
stand-up career.
You've sold out Madison Square
Garden multiple nights.
Radio City --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-It's like it's nothing.
Do you remember one of the worst
gigs that you played?
-Worst gigs?
It was in Manteca, California.
And it was a boxing ring.
Now, the problem with stand-up,
people think they can just
throw it up anywhere
and it's going to work.
So, we walked in and I asked
the guy, "Where's the stage?"
He goes,
"Well, it's the boxing ring."
I said, "Alright."
Now, on top of that,
there was a bowling alley
behind the boxing ring.
So, I'm doing jokes
while somebody behind me
is trying to pick up a spare,
alright?
[ Laughter ]
Doesn't really work well in
stand-up when you've got bowling
and blood on the floor
of the stage.
-No way. I love those gigs.
I remember that.
I remember there was one
restaurant that started.
They just go, "Let's just have
comedy night in the restaurant."
-Yeah, just throw it up.
-And I just started doing
stand-up in the middle of the --
People are just eating.
People are ordering hot wings,
and I'm going like --
I'm doing my act.
It was terrible.
-No introduction.
-No.
-They're like, "Go up."
I'm like, "No introduction?
No nothing?"
And I'm on a milk crate doing
jokes while people are --
-Do you ever do the gigs where
they don't have a microphone?
-Oh, yeah, yeah. "Just yell."
-"Just yell." Exactly, yeah.
"We'll have everyone be quiet."
I go, "I don't want everyone
to be quiet.
It's a stand-up show."
-Awful. It's awful.
-So, then you do your special
now, which,
by the way, I love the look.
I mean, you're in Vegas.
You got the tuxedo.
It's called "Sebastian
Maniscalco: Is It Me?"
Did you want to do like a whole
Rat Pack-y type of vibe?
-Yeah, I wanted a throwback
to the Rat Pack where
people, when they went out,
dressed up, had a tuxedo on.
I asked the audience
to dress up.
About 20 people did. Nice.
[ Laughter ]
I just wanted to do a throwback
because, you know, entertainment
back then seemed a little bit
more classy.
Bow tie, you know,
the whole thing.
So, that -- I gave it a little
nod to the Pack.
-Did you like Vegas?
Did you like playing Las Vegas?
-I like it.
You know, cross section between,
you know --
I like the Wynn Hotel.
That's where I like to perform.
It's got a nice vibe there.
Although Vegas has changed.
You know, I mean, you used to go
to the pool and lay out.
Now, you go to the pool
and you can't even get in.
I'm like,
"I just want to lay out."
They're like, "It's going to be
8 grand."
[ Laughter ]
-Just to lay out at the pool.
-To lay out on a lily pad
in the pool.
[ Laughter ]
-The title, you ask the
question, "Is it me?"
-Yeah.
-Is this based on something that
happens in your real life?
-Well, I constantly walk around
and look at today's environment,
and I go, "Is it me or...?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-People can relate.
But is it you?
Do you think it is us?
-The more and more I go
throughout the country,
I'm finding a lot of people are
agreeing with me.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. It's not just you.
-It's not just me.
-There's many more, yeah.
I want to show a little bit.
Here's "Sebastian Maniscalco:
Is It Me?"
Take a look at this special.
-So, the alarm went off
last month.
And my wife don't get up.
I'm up right away.
And I'm not one of these guys
that goes and handles it,
alright?
I'm like, "Get up. Get up!"
[ Laughter ]
She's like, "What?
What's going on?"
I said, "The alarm.
The alarm's on!"
She's like, "Oh, just go look."
Yeah, what? I'm going to go
look, take two to the head
while you escape out the back
with our two kids
and start another family with
some other guy.
[Bleep] that. Get on my back.
We're going out together.
"Go look."
[ Laughter and applause ]
The hell you think you married?
Rambo?
Let's go together.
-Start another family.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
Sebastian Maniscalco, everybody!
His stand-up special premieres
tomorrow globally on Netflix.
Beabadoobee performs
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.